Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Our guest for this episode is Dr. Deirdre Barrett, a psychologist and scholar of dreams, who's on the faculty of Harvard Medical School's Behavioral Medicine Program. She's the editor of the journal Dreaming and has written several books on the topic, including the Committee of Sleep. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Barrett. Hi, nice to be here.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。本期节目的嘉宾是迪尔德丽·巴雷特博士，她是一位心理学家，也是梦境研究学者，目前在哈佛医学院行为医学项目任教。她担任《梦境》杂志的编辑，并撰写了多本关于梦境的著作，其中包括《睡眠委员会》。感谢您参加我们的节目，巴雷特博士。你好，很高兴来到这里。
So dreams are always a fascinating time. topic and we all dream, but many people don't remember them or don't really know what to do with their dreams. And you as a scholar of dreams know all about dreams and are even a past president of the International Association for the study of dreams. So I'll start off, I think a simple question with probably a long answer, but why do we dream? Well, it's not a simple question. It's probably the one where you'd get the most disagreement among dream psychologists. Personally, I feel think that we have rapid eye movement sleep, which is the stage in which most dreams occur, along with all mammals, for a lot of reasons, many of which are very biological that certain
梦境一直是一个引人入胜的话题，我们每个人都会做梦，但许多人记不住梦境，或者不知道该如何处理自己的梦。作为一名梦境学者，您对梦境了如指掌，甚至还担任过国际梦境研究协会的前主席。所以我想先问一个简单的问题，虽然答案可能很长：我们为什么要睡觉做梦？嗯，这并不是一个简单的问题。这可能是梦境心理学家之间分歧最大的问题。就我个人而言，我认为我们拥有快速眼动睡眠（即大多数梦境发生的阶段），这与所有哺乳动物一样，原因有很多，其中许多是非常生物学层面的，比如某些
neurotransmitters are being replenished in the brain during that stage of sleep, that there's some very physical body reasons for REM that we share with all mammals. But I think evolution isn't that simple. And when something's been around since the dawn of mammals, it tends to have function upon function layered on top of it. And I think for humans, there's a lot of problem solving that goes on in that state. But that's my answer.
神经递质在睡眠的那个阶段会在大脑中得到补充，REM睡眠确实存在一些非常生理性的原因，这是我们与所有哺乳动物共有的。但我认为进化并没有那么简单。当某种事物从哺乳动物诞生之初就存在时，它往往会在其基础上叠加各种功能。我认为对于人类来说，在这种状态下会进行大量的解决问题的活动。但这就是我的答案。
And you would get everywhere from, you know, it has no function to, you know, dreams are our sort of wiser self-speaking to us from other dream psychologists. but that's my that's my concept of it yeah i mean i've always thought of it as sort of like it's telling you something you know your dreams are trying to maybe tell you something you have been avoiding or something you might not realize what's going on because it's really you're you know you are unconscious so i've always wondered if it's really your your sort of true self coming out
你会听到各种各样的观点，从“梦没有任何功能”，到其他梦境心理学家认为的“梦是我们更智慧的自我与我们对话”。但这就是我的观点。是的，我的意思是，我一直认为梦就像是在告诉你一些事情，你知道，你的梦可能试图告诉你一些你一直在回避的事情，或者你可能没有意识到正在发生的事情，因为这确实是你的潜意识。所以我一直想知道，这是否真的是你那所谓的“真我”在显露。
so i'm probably maybe in that camp just as a lay person just being interested in the study of dreams yeah i mean i like to say it's just it's our brain thinking and a different biochemical state. And I don't buy into the perspective that there's one book called Dreams are Wiser than Men. I don't think that what our dream, dreaming mind is thinking about an issue is always the correct one or wiser than our waking one. I think the benefit of dreams lie in just what a different biochemical state it is. So if we're kind of stuck in our usual everyday rational thinking, dreams may make an in run around that and show us something very different. But if you had to operate off one or the other, I think our waking mind is probably giving us
所以我可能属于那一派，作为一个对梦境研究感兴趣的门外汉。是的，我的意思是，我喜欢说这只是我们的大脑在不同的生化状态下进行思考。我不认同那本名为《梦比人更智慧》的书中的观点。我不认为我们的梦境思维对某个问题的看法总是正确的，或者比清醒时的思维更智慧。我认为梦的好处就在于它所处的生化状态不同。因此，如果我们陷入了日常理性的思维定式，梦境可能会绕过它，向我们展示一些非常不同的东西。但如果你必须在两者之间做出选择，我认为我们清醒时的思维可能比梦境思维能提供更多好的建议。但梦是一个很好的补充。绝对是这样。那么，您能解释一下国际梦境研究协会（IASD）是做什么的吗？它是一个非营利组织，其使命就是传播。它是一个机构，旨在传播关于梦境的信息，这涵盖了从关于梦境长期以来已知的最基础的教育（面向公众甚至儿童），到在领域内的专业人士之间传播最新研究成果。IASD每年举办一次国际会议。它还有一些在线虚拟会议、一些区域性会议，并出版两份刊物。我编辑《梦境》杂志，
more good advice than our dreaming one. But the dream is a great supplement. Absolutely. And can you explain a bit about what the International Association for the Study of Dreams does? It's a non-profit organization whose mission is just to dissemination. It's a business. It's a disseminate information about dreams, and that's everything from the most basic education about things that have been known about dreams for a long time, to the general public and even to children, on to disseminating the latest research between professionals in the field. The ISD has one international conference a year. It has some online virtual conferences. It has some regional conferences, and it has two publications. I edit the journal Dreaming, which
IASD负责监督内容，但美国心理学会（APA）是我们的出版商，这是一份面向领域内专业人士的学术期刊。但IASD还有另一份名为《梦境时光》的刊物，那是一本杂志，内容是对梦境更非正式的讨论，深受大众喜爱。是的，这非常有趣。直到我研究这个话题之前，我都不知道还有这样一个协会。是的，这是一个很棒的团体。我推荐它的网站，对于任何能参加的人来说，它的会议都很棒。而且与许多组织不同，它是专业人士和非专业人士的结合体。
ISD oversees the content, but APA is our publisher, and that is an academic journal for professionals in the field. But IASD also has another publication called Dreamtime, which is a magazine, which is much more informal discussion of dreams that the general public enjoy. Yeah, it's very interesting. Until I was... researching this topic, I didn't know there was such an association. Yeah, it's a great group. I recommend its website, and for anyone that can get there, its conferences are great. And unlike many organizations, it's a combination of professional and not professional.
所以在会议上，超过一半的演讲者和大约一半的参会者是该领域的专业人士，但也有许多对梦境极其感兴趣的人选择来参加会议。有趣。也许有一天我也会去那里。那么，你知道，有一些常见的梦，我想你读到过，在电视和电影中看到过，人们也会谈论，比如在公共场合赤身裸体，或者牙齿掉落，或者被人追赶。
So at the conference, more than half the presenters and about half the attendees are some kind of professional in the field, but there are lots of people who are just extremely dream interested who choose to come to the conference. Interesting. Maybe I'll end up there one day. So, you know, there's those common dreams that I think, you know, you read about, see in television and movies and people talk about, like being in a public place naked or having your teeth fall out or being chased.
那么为什么不同的人会做相似的梦呢？我想我一直觉得这个问题非常有趣。就像，为什么我会和某个来自不同生活背景的陌生人做同样的梦？关于这些共同的主题有研究吗？嗯，有一些关于它们发生频率的研究，这确实证明了其中的一些主题，包括你刚才提到的那些，
So why do different people have similar dreams? I think I've always found that question really interesting. It's like, why would I have the same dream as some random person from, you know, a different walk of life? And has there been research into those common themes? Well, there's some research just on how frequently they occur and that does demonstrate that a few of those themes, including the ones you rattled off,
在不同年龄段和世界各地的人们中确实发生得相当频繁。有些比其他的更具普遍性。这往往取决于它们所代表的隐喻是否具有普遍性。显然，所有文化对于你应该遮盖身体的哪些部位都有一些规范，即使在一种文化中可能只是遮盖生殖器的一条小丁字裤，而在另一种文化中是从头到脚包裹起来，但关于你展示多少身体以及展示超过规定范围的身体所带来的羞耻感，依然存在。
do occur pretty frequently to people of different ages and around the world. And some are more universal than others. And it tends to go with whether the metaphor they seem to be representing is universal. Clearly, all cultures have some norms about what parts of your body you're supposed to cover and not even if it's, you know, a tiny thong just covering your genitals in one culture and bailing, you know, from head to toe and another one, there's still a, how much of your body do you show and shame around showing more than you're supposed to.
所以，在公共场合赤身裸体的梦似乎是相当普遍的。我稍后会多说一点，但我们当然不认为你应该简单地说，同一个梦境主题对任何做梦的人来说都意味着完全相同的事情。总有一个个体因素在里面。但像“在公共场合赤身裸体”这样的事情，更有可能代表社会羞耻感、社交焦虑，你知道，关于以某种不舒服的方式暴露自己的常识性隐喻，通常就是大多数做这个梦的人所经历的。然后还有其他一些更具文化局限性的共同主题，比如大多数西方社会，伴随着我们的那种学校教育。文化中的许多人都会反复做关于考试出错的梦。
to be. So the naked and public one seems to be quite universal. And I'll say, I'll say more a bit later about this, but we certainly don't think that you should ever just say one dream theme means exactly the same thing for anyone that dreams it. There's always an individual element. But there's some things like naked and public that are much likelier to be representing social shame, social anxieties, you know, just the common sense metaphor about being exposed in some uncomfortable way is usually what that dream is about for most of the people having it. Then there are other common themes that are a little more cultural bound, like most Western societies with our kind of schooling. Many, many people in the culture have recurring dreams about tests going wrong.
你睡过头了。你错过了考试。你找不到教室在哪里。你迟到了。你找不到教室。你进入考场。你意识到你复习错了科目，试卷是用象形文字写的。
You've overslept. You've missed the test. You aren't figuring out where the classroom is. You're late. You can't find the classroom. You get into the exam. You realize you've studied. the wrong subject for it, the exams in hieroglyphics.
各种各样的变体都有，但不知何故，你就是要搞砸一场考试。我们在西方学校教育类型的文化中经常看到这种情况，但在狩猎采集部落中却看不到，因为在那些地方，学习如何走出去以某种更像实习的方式完成成人任务是他们的教育方式，显然，他们没有坐下来参加考试的梦。即使在我们的文化中，那些从小就决定想成为演员或音乐家的人，也会有一种变体，那就是“试镜梦”。他们不是坐下来参加考试，而是带着乐器出现，却意识到自己准备错了曲目，或者找不到试镜大厅。
They're just all kinds of variations, but somehow you are, you know, about to mess up a test. And we see that in in Western schooling type cultures all the time, but you don't see that in hunter-gatherer tribes where, you know, learning to get out there and do adult tasks in some sort of, you know, more intern-like way is the way that they're educated and tests, obviously, they don't have sit-down exam dreams. And even in our culture, people who decide to be, want to be actors or musicians from an early age, they'll have a variation that's the audition dream. They're not sitting down to take an exam, but they're showing up with their musical instrument and they realize they've studied the wrong piece of music or they can't find the audition
所以，即使在那些标准的梦境中也存在一些差异，但“存在一些普遍的、非常频繁的梦，且对大多数做梦者意味着相似的事情”这一观点是有道理的。而这些梦境背后的感受，就像你说的，可能是某种羞耻感，或者对某种方式的测试感到焦虑，诸如此类。所以它们背后有共同的感受。嗯，是的，对于不同的梦有不同的细微差别，但正如它们通常是共同的隐喻一样。你知道，如果你“感到暴露”或“感到赤身裸体”，那通常更多是关于羞耻感、
Hall. So, so, so, so, so there's some variation even in those, those standard ones, but, but, there, there's something to the idea that there's some universal, very frequent dreams, meaning something similar for most people who have them. And those feelings behind those dreams could be, like you said, maybe some, some, some sorts of shame or some sorts of anxiety about what's, what's going to be, happened to be tested in some way, that sort of thing. So they're common feelings that underlie them. Well, and yeah, different, different shades for for different ones, but just in line with sort of what they otherwise are common metaphor. You know, if you, quote, feel exposed or feel naked, that's usually more of a shame
社会不认可。如果你正在被测试，那更多是权威人物在评估你，即你是否达到了社会或权威的标准。所以，大多数反复出现的主题梦都是焦虑梦，但无论是关于能力问题还是社会适宜性问题，这些往往由不同的具体事物来代表。我听说有些人说梦根本没有任何意义，它们只是你在睡觉时大脑产生的随机冲动，或者可能只是在巩固记忆，诸如此类，它们背后没有更深层的情感意义。但是，许多人确实相信梦很重要，它们有助于解决问题，或许还能激发灵感，我稍后会问这个问题。那么心理学研究对梦的重要性有什么看法？
social disapproval. If you're being tested, you know, that's more than authority figure is evaluating you, sort of are you measuring up, you know, to society in general or an authority. So, you know, so there, most of the recurring themed dreams are anxiety dreams, but whether, whether it's about sort of being competent versus being socially appropriate, those, those tend to be represented by different specific things. And I've heard that some people say that dreams don't mean anything at all, that they're just random impulses from your brain when you're sleeping or perhaps just, you know, consolidating memories, that sort of thing. and that there's no deeper emotional meaning behind them. But, you know, many people do believe dreams are important that they help problem solve, perhaps find inspiration, which I'll ask in a few minutes. But what does the psychological research say about the importance of dreams?
我们知道如果我们不做梦会发生什么吗？嗯，让我先回答第一部分。这稍微简单一点。确实有一些研究。剥夺人们的REM睡眠是有限度的。而且必须是剥夺REM睡眠。并非所有的梦都发生在REM睡眠中。如果你剥夺人们的REM睡眠，你会看到的一件事是
And do we know what would happen if we didn't dream? Well, let me answer the first part first. It's a little simpler. there is some research. There's a limit to how much you can deprive people of REM sleep. And it does have to be depriving of REM sleep. Not quite all dreams happen in REM sleep. And one of the things that you see if you deprive people of REM sleep
你开始收到更多听起来像是完整的梦境叙述，这些叙述来自睡眠的其他阶段。其中一些无论如何都会发生。但这就像有一种做梦的压力，如果你不让它在快速眼动睡眠中发生，它就会开始在睡眠的其他阶段发生。在极端情况下，在一些实验中，人们似乎甚至在清醒时也会产生幻觉。所以确实存在一种可以突破REM睡眠的做梦压力，
is that you begin to get more reports that sound like full-fledged dream narratives out of other stages of sleep. A few of those happen anyway. But it's like there's some pressure to dream that if you don't let it happen in rapid eye movement sleep, it begins to happen in other stages of sleep. And then in the extreme, in some of the experiments, people seemed to hallucinate, even awake a little bit. So there's certainly a pressure to dream that can sort of break out of REM,
并不是说它总是完全局限在那里。但另一件事是，如果你剥夺人们的REM睡眠，你会看到某些方面的缺陷，或者甚至不需要是REM剥夺，你可以做一个实验，在接触一项任务和重试它之间经过相同的时间，人们要么得到要么得不到REM睡眠阶段。从这些实验来看，睡眠的其他阶段似乎更多地与巩固一些简单直接的记忆有关，而快速眼动睡眠则是在巩固和学习更多带有情感色彩的记忆，以及某些需要从单个案例的答案中进行抽象概括并开始看到模式的解决问题能力。在接触某些解决问题的任务之间获得REM睡眠周期的人表现得更好。所以那是REM睡眠，而不是在谈论梦境内容。但我们确实在梦境内容中，有时会看到非常明显的解决问题的过程。有人在做梦看到解决方案之前，不知道问题的答案。所以无论你是否记得梦境内容，REM在生物学上都在做些什么，但再次强调，对于人类来说，梦境是在REM之上叠加的。梦境似乎在思考我们刚刚接触到的问题和议题，有时还能解决它们。说到你刚才提到的关于人们如何利用梦境来解决问题或获得灵感，
not that it's always totally confined there. But the other thing is if you're REM depriving people, you see deficits in certain things, or it doesn't even have to be REM deprivation, but you can do an experiment where the same amount of time passes between exposure to a task and retrying it, and people either do or don't get a REM episode in there. And from those experiments, it looks like other stages of sleep have mortgages. do with consolidating some simple straightforward kinds of memory and that rapid eye movement sleep is consolidating and learning more emotionally tinged memories and certain kinds of problem solving that require some abstract generalization from answers to single cases and beginning to see a
你在你的书《睡眠委员会》中写到了一些来自著名艺术家和发明家的故事，比如保罗·麦卡特尼、萨尔瓦多·达利和缝纫机的发明者，他们是如何从梦中获得灵感，从而创作出美丽的艺术作品和像缝纫机这样的实用工具的。你能解释一下我们是如何利用梦境来解决问题和寻找灵感的吗？是的。我的意思是，这有两个方面。一个是它经常自发地发生，那些被问题困住的人会做一个突破性的梦。缝纫机的发明者就是这种情况。那个梦是凭空出现的，他并没有以任何特定的方式去寻求它，但梦向他展示了如何制造缝纫机。
pattern across them, that people that get a REM period in between exposure to certain problem solving tasks do better. So that's REM sleep and that's not talking about the dream content. But we definitely, at dream content, we sometimes see very overt problem solving pop up. Somebody doesn't know the answer to a question until they have a dream that shows them the solution. So REM is doing something with that biologically, whether you're remembering dream content with it or not, but, but again, layered on top of REM for human beings, dreams. Dreams seem to be thinking about the problems and issues we've just been exposed to and sometimes solving them. And speaking about you just mentioned about how people use them to problem solver
有两种问题很可能在梦中自发解决。一种是任何视觉空间方面的问题，因为梦境非常直观。我们可以以幻觉的方式在我们面前看到事物。所以第一台计算机控制的防空炮是在梦中构思出来的，缝纫机是在梦中构思出来的，苯分子的结构也是在梦中构思出来的。
inspiration. And you wrote about in your book, The Committee of Sleep, about some stories from famous artists and inventors like Paul McCartney, Salvador Dali, and the inventor of the sewing machine, how they received inspiration from their dreams, which produced beautiful works of art and practical tools like the sewing machine. Can you explain how we use dreams to problem solve and to find inspiration? Yes. I mean, there are two aspects of that. One is that it it simply happens spontaneously a fair bit that people who are stuck on a problem will have a breakthrough dream. And that was true in the case of the sewing machine inventor. That dream came out of nowhere without his asking for it in any particular way and showed him how to make the sewing machine.
所有这些似乎都是这样的案例：能够比清醒时仅靠视觉想象更清晰地看到事物，是其中的一个有益部分。另一类由梦境解决的大问题是，你因为传统观念的错误而陷入困境。苯分子就是两者的例子。凯库勒知道苯中的原子是什么，但在当时，所有已知的分子都是某种带有侧链的直线。
And two kinds of problems are likely to get solved. spontaneously in dreams. One is anything that's a very visual spatial, because dreams are so visual. We can see things in a hallucinatory way in front of us. So the first computer-controlled anti-aircraft gun was dreamed, the sewing machine was dreamed, the structure of the benzene molecule was dreamed.
所以他试图以某种有意义并能解释其化学性质的方式将原子排列成直线。但这行不通。他睡着了，梦见分子在他眼前跳舞，他说它们是蛇，但它们是直线的分子。最终，其中一条由原子组成的蛇绕过来，用嘴咬住了自己的尾巴。他醒来后意识到苯是一个闭合的环。但所有的化学家当时都会试图把它做成某种直线。
And all of those seem to be cases. where being able to see the thing very much more clearly than you could just do visual imagination awake was a helpful part of it. The other big cluster of solved by dreams are where you're stuck because the conventional wisdom is wrong. The benzene molecule is an example of both. Kekulae knew what the atoms in benzene were, but at that time, all known molecules were some kind of straight line with a side chain.
所以做梦绕过了那种“必须这样做，必须那样做”的传统观念，并展示了更多的可能性。因此，非常直观的问题或需要跳出框框思考的问题，很可能会从梦中得到帮助。但另一个方面是，虽然这些是自发发生的，但如果人们试图将梦境集中在特定的主题上，我们在心理学中称之为“梦境孵化”，即对自己说：“今晚我想梦到某个问题的答案，或者我只想梦到这个特定的主题。”你比不这样做作为睡前自我暗示时，更有可能梦到那个主题，甚至得到问题的答案。所以每个人往往都能从梦中得到一些帮助、灵感和好的建议，但通过要求你的梦境专注于特定的主题，你可以得到更多。是的，这真的很有趣。我想趁现在谈谈这一点。那么，如果你想更好地记住你的梦，并且想拥有一个梦境日记并利用它来解决问题，因为有时人们会说，“哦，我做梦了，但我记不住。”你对此有什么建议吗？对于某个人来说，他们该如何更好地记住他们的
And so he was trying to arrange the atoms in a straight line in some way that made sense and explained the chemical properties. And that wasn't working. And he fell asleep and dreamed of molecules dancing in front of his eyes, farming, he said snakes, but they were straight lines of molecules. And eventually one of the snakes made of atoms reached around and took its tail in its mouth. And he woke up realizing that benzene was a closed ring. but all chemists would have been approaching it to make it some kind of straight line.
梦，然后如何写梦境日记？好的。嗯，第一个建议是最陈词滥调的，但它确实是最重要的。比普通美国人睡得更多。如果你每晚睡八个小时，你会比睡得少的人记住更多的梦。是的。而且这不是……我们每晚大约每90分钟进入一次快速眼动睡眠，但每个REM周期都在变长。所以第一个周期只有几分钟，而最后一个周期可以接近半小时。所以如果你睡四个小时而不是八个小时，你就没有得到你一半的做梦时间。当你缩短睡眠时间时，你得到的做梦时间只有20%或更少，因为梦境
So dreaming just bypasses that conventional wisdom. It has to be done this way. It has to be done this way. And shows more possibilities. So very visual problems or problems where you need to think outside the box are likely to get help from dreams. But then the other aspect is that although these happen spontaneously, if people are trying to focus their dreams on a particular topic. We tend to call it dream incubation in psychology to say, tonight I want to dream the answer to a particular problem or I just want to dream on this
每90分钟来一次，但它们在夜间会变得长得多。所以保证充足的睡眠极其重要。这是拥有高低梦境回忆率的最简单因素。但其他因素是意图。我的意思是，通常参加梦境课程或阅读梦境书籍的人，因为梦境变得更相关，他们会记住更多的梦。事实上，今天听播客的人，仅仅因为做了这件事，今晚就比平时更有可能记住一个梦。但你可以通过我刚才提到的解决问题的“梦境孵化”来增加这一点，只是专注于回忆。如果你在入睡时告诉自己：“我今晚想记住我的梦。我今晚想记住我的梦。”
particular topic. You're much likelier to have a dream on that topic or even an answer to the problem than if you weren't doing that as a self-suggestion at bedtime. So everybody tends to get some help and inspiration and good advice from their dreams, but you can get more by asking your dreams to focus on particular topics. Yeah, that's really interesting. And I'm going to just touch on that while we're there. So if you, how do you use dreams to, you know, if you want to remember your dream better and you want to be able to have a dream journal and use it for those that problem solving, like I said, because sometimes people say, oh, I dream where I don't remember it. What tips do you have for that? So for someone who, how they can remember their
这会增加可能性。然后正如你已经提到的，保留某种梦境日记，你在早晨所做的事情同样重要。首先，除了日记之外，自然醒比闹钟醒更好，但，你知道，我知道不是每个人都能做到。是的，这很困难。无论你以哪种方式醒来，如果你躺在那里一会儿，试着什么都不想，只去想你的梦，如果你已经回忆起来了，如果你不打算写下来或录音，至少在脑海中复述一遍。但如果你刚醒来时没有回忆起梦境，就躺在那里，看看你的脑海里有什么内容。比如，你醒来时是不是在想你的兄弟？
dream better and then how to do a dream journal? Okay. Well, the first tip is the most banal, but it's really the most important. Get more sleep than the average America does. If you get eight hours of sleep and night, you will remember a lot more dreams than if you're getting less than that. Yeah. And it's not, um, we interact. rapid eye movement sleep about every 90 minutes through the night, but each REM period is getting longer. So the first one is just a few minutes, whereas the last one can be getting closer to half an hour in length. So if you sleep four hours instead of eight, you're not getting half your dream time. You're getting 20% or less of your dream time when you truncate your sleep because the dreams are
或者你醒来时感觉有点难过？因为有时如果你只是专注于那一点点内容，梦境就会涌现回来。哦，是的，我在想我的兄弟，因为我梦见他做了什么。我很难过，因为我梦见了刚刚发生的事情。所以梦境记忆非常脆弱，有时当你刚醒来时，它就在那里徘徊。所以先不要做任何其他事情，先专注于梦境。其次，记录下来不仅很好，而且往往能把它固定在你的脑海里，即使你以后不怎么翻看梦境日记。
coming every 90 minutes, but they're getting much longer through the night. So getting enough sleep is extremely important. That's the simplest car with high and low dream recall. But other things are the intent. I mean, often people that are taking class on dreams or reading a book on dreams will just, it becoming more relevant, they'll remember more dreams. In fact, People listening to today's podcast are likely to remember a dream tonight just by virtue of doing that than otherwise. But you can increase that with, again, a dream incubation like I was talking about for problem solving, but just focused on recall. If you're just telling yourself as you fall asleep, I want to remember my dreams tonight. I want to remember my dreams tonight.
所以有些人仍然喜欢用漂亮的皮质日记本手写，这对某些人来说是一种很好的联想。你知道，或者如果你的笔记本电脑就在床边，你可以伸手去打字。但我知道很多人都在使用智能手机。有各种各样的应用程序。Dreams Cloud就是其中之一，DreamScope，它们有应用程序，你可以通常在应用程序上设置闹钟，用它代替另一个闹钟。
That increases the likelihood. And then as you already alluded to, keeping some sort of dream journal, what you do in the morning is just as important. First of all, aside from the journal, just it's better to wake up naturally than to an alarm clock, but, you know, I know everyone can't do that. Yes, it is difficult. Whichever way you wake up, if you lie there for a moment and try to think about nothing other than your dream, if you already recall it, if you're not going to write it down or tell it to a recorder, at least rehearse it in your mind. But if you don't recall a dream when you first wake up, just lie there and see what content at all is there in your mind. Like, did you wake up kind of thinking about your brother?
它们有各种更柔和的铃声来叫醒你，甚至有一个声音说“你刚才梦到了什么”，这是你听到的第一件事。然后你的手机已经设置好了，如果你在回应闹钟或那个声音时说话，它会自动录音，而不需要你伸手去激活它。所以这些是最简单的方法，而且它们都有语音转文字功能。所以你就有了一个记录。
Or did you wake up feeling a little sad? Because sometimes if you just stay focused on that hint of content, a dream will come rushing back. Oh yeah, I was thinking about my brother because I dreamed that he did thus. I was sad because I this dream this just happened. So dream memory is very fragile and sometimes it's hovering there as you first wake up. So don't do anything else first before focusing on the dream. And secondly, recording it is nice to have the record but also tends to fix it in your your mind, even if you're not referring back to the Dream Journal that much.
所以我认识的很多人现在，我仍然会打字，但我的大多数学生都在手机上使用应用程序。是的，利用科技来记录梦境很有趣。我注意到我通常会，我必须做那种“徘徊”，就是我有点像，“我梦到了什么？”我会回忆一下。然后我可以把它牢牢地植入我的记忆中，然后有机会时我会写下来。我曾经在上班的地铁上这样做过。坐在那里疯狂地在我的日记本、我的笔记本上写。
So some people still prefer to handwrite things in beautiful leather-bound journals, have a sort of a nice association for some people. You know, or you can, if your laptops next to your bed, you can reach for it and type. But I know that a lot of people are using their smartphones. There are all sorts of apps. Dreams Cloud is one of them, DreamScope, that have apps where you generally you can set your alarm on the app, make that your alarm in lieu of the other one.
我只是不想忘记任何事情。是的，在脑海中复述它，我的意思是，特别是在半夜，如果你不想通过说出你的梦来打扰床伴，如果你只是在脑海中过一遍，这往往会把它固定在长期记忆中，因为否则，很多人会记得半夜从梦中醒来，然后说，“哦，哇，那真是一个奇怪的梦。”而这就是你关于它所记得的一切。
And they have all sorts of gentler tones to wake you up or even a voice saying, what were you dreaming, as the first thing you're going to hear. and then your phone is already set to if you speak in response to the alarm or the voice saying, what were you dreaming? It's automatically going to record without you're having to reach over and activate it or anything. So those are some of the easiest, you know, and then they all do speech to text. So you have an account of it.
或者甚至，“我不需要写下这个。我肯定会记得这个。”然后你就忘了。但如果你即使不写下来，如果你把它过一遍，那就会把它从短期记忆转为长期记忆。回到梦境的内容，为什么有些人会做重复的梦？我们对重复的梦意味着什么了解多少？重复的梦通常被认为是对于那个人来说更重要的主题。
So a lot of the people I know these days, I still type mine out, but most of my students use an app on their phones. Yeah, that's interesting using technology for our dreams. And I noticed that I usually will like, I have to do the hovering where I kind of like, what did I dream? I'll kind of recall it. And then I can sort of get it firmly planted in my memory and then I'll write it down when I get the chance. I've been known to do that on the metro on the way to work. Sitting furiously writing in my journal, my notebook I have.
弗洛伊德谈到了“日间残留”，这是他至今仍被认真对待的概念之一，即在过去18小时内发生的事情比其他随机的过去几天更有可能出现在你的梦中。所以很多梦是关于非常近期的事件，它们可能是关于那天刚刚发生的事情的一次性担忧。而且，你知道，它们仍然值得解读，但它们将是关于一个非常具体的当前问题。而如果一个梦反复出现，
Just I don't want to forget anything. Yeah, just rehearsing it in your mind, I mean, especially like in the middle of the night, if you don't want to disturb a bed partner by speaking your dream or something, if you just kind of run through it in your mind, that tends to fix it into long-term memory because otherwise, so many people recall waking up from a dream in the middle of the night and going, oh, wow, that was such a weird dream. And that's all you remember about it.
我的意思是，它可能是由特定一天的事件触发的，可能会使一个长期问题变得更加突出，但它肯定会是关于那个人的某种长期性格逻辑问题。所以总的来说，我们认为重复的梦在某种程度上更重要。如果你只有时间分析几个梦，你的重复梦将是目标。而且人们经常谈论做噩梦或暴力梦。我和朋友们谈过，你知道，包括我自己，我们都做过那些
Or even, I don't need to write this one down. I'm certainly going to remember this one. And then you don't. But if you, even without writing it down, if you play it through, that kind of gets it from short term to long term memory. And going back to the content of dreams, why do some people have recurring dreams? And what do we know about what reoccurring dreams mean? Recurring dreams are usually thought to be themes that are more important for that,
可怕的梦。那么那些梦意味着什么？如果你经常做暴力梦或噩梦，该怎么办？嗯，有两种非常不同的类型。一种是隐喻性的，它们很可怕，但除此之外，内容看起来和其他梦很像。它是相当隐喻性的，比如在旧建筑的走廊里追赶你之类的。孩子们比成年人做更多那种“花园品种”的隐喻性噩梦。它们往往随着年龄的增长而减少，但几乎每个人都有过几次。另一种是创伤后噩梦，即你遭受过一次或多次极其暴力、恐怖的清醒生活事件。在创伤后噩梦中，事件往往像在清醒时一样展开。
person. Freud talked about day residue, and it's one of his concepts that's still taken quite seriously, the idea that things that happen in the preceding 18 hours are much likely to show up in your dream than sort of other random previous days. And so lots of dreams are about very recent events, and they may be one-time concerns about a about things that just happened that day. And, you know, and they're still worth interpreting, but they're going to be about a very specific current sort of issue. Whereas if a dream recurs over and over,
有些人，它就像在重播一段视频，完全像他们经历的那样，比如被强奸、身处战场或房子在他们周围烧毁，一遍又一遍，完全像发生时那样。或者更常见的是，它非常接近发生的情况，但要么带有一点奇怪的梦境扭曲，但没有大多数梦那么多，或者通常创伤后噩梦会更进一步，比如现实生活中有人用枪指着某人的头威胁要扣动扳机，而他们真的扣动了扳机。梦境，就像梦境更进一步，无论最害怕什么即将发生，它真的发生了。所以“花园品种”的噩梦，它们在一定程度上是正常的。
it, I mean, it may be activated by events of a particular day, may make a long-term issue more salient, but it's certainly going to be about something that's a kind of long-term character logic issue for that person. So in general, we think of, recurring dreams as somewhat more important. If you only have time to analyze a few dreams, your recurring dreams would be ones to target. And often people talk about having nightmares or violent dreams. And I've spoken to friends and, you know, myself included, we've had those
而且有些做这些梦的人并不特别介意。我听过很多人说这有点像恐怖电影，你知道，有一种肾上腺素激增，他们有点享受。这是他们的噩梦，我也听过其他人说他们不喜欢，但他们觉得学到了东西，就像它总是指出他们焦虑但没想到的事情。所以许多做那种“花园品种”噩梦的人并不特别希望它们消失。我认为像解读其他梦一样解读它们，思考，你知道，
kind of scary dreams. So what do those dreams mean? And what do you do if you have violent dreams or nightmares often? Well, there are two very different kinds. One is the, The metaphoric, they're scary, but otherwise the content seems much like other dreams. It's fairly metaphoric, which is chasing you down a hall in an old building or something. And children have more of those kind of garden variety metaphor nightmares than adults. They tend to decrease with age, but almost everyone has a few of those. versus post-traumatic nightmares where you've suffered one or more extremely violent, terrifying, waking life events. And in post-traumatic nightmares, the event tends to unfold very much like it did awake.
在我的清醒生活中，什么感觉像那种感觉。当女巫在走廊里追我时，我胃里的那种感觉，就是处理这些梦的方法。但创伤后噩梦只会让人们再次受到创伤。这就像可怕的事件夜复一夜地再次发生，以至于它永远不会退回到过去。每个人都有创伤后噩梦，讨厌做这些梦。没人喜欢那些。
Some people, it replays exactly like they were in a video of the episode of getting raped or being in this, battlefield or house burning down around them over and over and over exactly like it happened. Or more commonly, it's pretty close to how it happened, but it's either got a bit of bizarre dream distortion, but not as much as most dreams, or often the post-traumatic nightmares go one step further, like somebody was holding a gun to someone's head threatening to pull the trigger in real life, and they actually do pull the trigger in the gun. The dream, like the dream goes one step further, whatever was most feared is about to happen, actually happens. So garden variety nightmares, they're just normal to a certain extent.
而且我认为这也不是什么谜。你知道，如果你被强奸了，你梦见强奸，或者你的房子烧毁了，你每晚都梦见火焰，这不像女巫那样，会让人觉得“天哪，你为什么梦见那个？”所以有一些技术可以让人们停止做创伤后噩梦，包括。你可以指导人们如果开始做梦就醒来，但似乎更有效的方法是让人们想出一个替代方案，一种“掌控梦”。如果噩梦再次开始，你希望它有什么不同的结局？心理学家偶然发现了这种技术，因为它偶尔会
And some people who have them don't particularly mind them. I've heard a lot of people either say that it's kind of like horror films, that, you know, there's a kind of adrenaline rush and they kind of enjoy. They're nightmares, and I've heard other people who say they don't enjoy them, but they feel like they learn something, like it's always pointing out to them things they're anxious about that they hadn't thought of. So many people who have nightmares of that kind of garden variety type don't particularly want them to go away. And I think that interpreting them just like you would other dreams, thinking about, you know,
自发发生。人们反复做关于真实事件的噩梦。突然之间，他们会做一个梦，有人来救他们，或者他们确实击退了攻击者，或者以一种非常梦幻、神奇的方式，整个创伤被扫除了。他们醒来时感觉好多了。所以我们发现PTSD小组中的一些人会听到有人说，“哦，我曾经做噩梦，直到有一天我做了另一个美妙的梦。”仅仅听到这个，下周小组里的其他几个病人就会说他们也做了。
what in my waking life, you know, feels like that feeling. and pit of my stomach when the witch is chasing me down the hall is, you know, the way to deal with those. But post-traumatic nightmares just re-traumatized people. It's like having the horrible event happening again night after night after night so that it never recedes into the past. And everyone has post-traumatic nightmares hates having them. Nobody likes those.
所以现在我们指导人们想出一个他们希望看到的替代方案，并进行个性化处理。我的意思是，对于听起来相同的创伤，有些人宁愿有人救他们。另一些人宁愿自己击退攻击者。许多性虐待幸存者最想做的是告诉施虐者为什么这是如此错误。而其他人想要非常神奇的，你知道，把攻击者或火缩小到四分之一英寸高，那种梦幻般的事情。所以一旦你想出了一个替代方案，
And I think that it's also not a mystery. you know, if you were raped and you're dreaming about a rape or your house burned down and you're dreaming about flames every night, there's not a, gee, why are you dreaming that like there is about the witch? So there are techniques that can make people stop having post-traumatic nightmares that involve. You can coach people to just wake up if they start, but it seems to be even more effective to have people come up with an alternate scenario, a kind of mastery dream. If the nightmare starts again, how would you like it to come out differently? And psychologists kind of happened onto this technique because it happens occasionally,
你在睡前练习那个。这又是“梦境孵化”的另一种变体，只是告诉自己，你知道，“如果我的创伤性噩梦开始，我，你知道，我想要，你知道，这个场景”，并想象那个替代方案。场景，这对于很多人来说是有效的。很多人做了替代梦，然后就再也没有做过那个噩梦了。然后在研究中，有些人做了那个
spontaneously. People have had a nightmare over and over and over about a real event. All of a sudden we'll have this dream where someone comes and rescues them or they do fight off the attacker or in a very dreamlike magical way, the whole trauma is swept away. And they wake up feeling so much better. And so we found that some people in PTSD groups would hear somebody say, oh, I used to have a nightmare until one night I had this other wonderful dream. And just hearing that the next week, a couple other patients in the group would say they had.
噩梦就停止了，而他们至少没有有意识地回忆起做过替代梦，所以我们真的不知道他们是否做了并忘记了，但它仍然达到了目的，或者仅仅是睡前清醒时的场景可视化，对某些人来说也有类似的效果。是的，你对这个有某种控制力，这真的很迷人。我的意思是，如果你告诉自己你想要这个梦停止或达到一个更好的结论，这真的很迷人。是的。我的意思是，我们大脑中与记忆相关的区域并不完全活跃，
So now we coach people to come up with an alternate scenario that they would like to see happen and kind of get an individual. I mean, for the same sounding trauma, some people would rather have someone rescue them. Other people would rather fight off some attacker themselves. A lot of sexual abuse survivors would most like to tell off the abuser about why this was so wrong. and other people want very magical, you know, shrink the attacker or the fire down, you know, to a quarter inch high, dream-like things. So once you come up with an alternate scenario,
但当我们做梦时，它们确实在某种程度上是清醒的。所以对我们梦境思维的请求确实经常能传达过去。这不是一对一的，你知道，只要求一次，你就会梦到这个主题。或者你会做这个其他的梦。但它经常是有效的，特别是在不止一个晚上的重复下。转到宠物，我们说。我知道你说过动物，哺乳动物确实会进入REM睡眠。但是，你知道，如果你观察过地上的宠物狗，当它们的思想开始入睡时，
you practice that at bedtime. This is, again, another variation on dream incubation, just telling yourself, you know, if my traumatic nightmare starts, I, you know, I want, you know, this scenario and picture the alternate. scenario and and that that works for a lot of people a lot of people have the alternate dream and then never have the nightmare again and then in the research studies some people do that
我的狗会叫，她，你知道，抽搐或喜欢，诸如此类。所以看起来它们在做梦，你知道，据我们所知。但动物会做梦吗？我们怎么知道它们是否做梦？嗯，这是一个非常，这是一个非常好的问题。我倾向于认为它们会。我们知道除了鲸类动物以外的所有哺乳动物。鲸鱼和海豚没有REM睡眠。它们有这种奇怪的睡眠，它们用一只手睡觉。
and the nightmares stop without their at least consciously recalling having the alternate dreams so we don't really know if they have it and forget it but it still serves its purpose or if simply the visualization of the scenario, you know, awake at bedtime has a similar effect for some people. Yeah, it's really fascinating that you have some control over this. I mean, if you tell yourself you want this dream to stop or to reach a better conclusion, that's really fascinating. Yes. I mean, the areas in our brain associated with memory are not quite as active,
它们大脑的一半在工作。但所有其他哺乳动物都在非REM睡眠和快速眼动睡眠之间交替，它们的大脑活动看起来与我们做梦时非常相似。所以我愿意跨出这一步，说我认为哺乳动物在做梦，无论它们是大象、老鼠、狗还是猫的版本。我的一些同事不会，不会那样说。我的意思是，我的一些同事不会假设其他哺乳动物物种有任何意识，或者只有进化等级中超过一定水平的才有。
but they're certainly somewhat awake as we dream. So requests to our dreaming mind do very often get through. It's not a one-to-one, you know, just ask for it once, and you'll dream on this topic. Or you'll have this other dream. But it's very often effective, especially with repetition more than one night. And moving on to pets, let's say. I know you said animals, mammals do go into REM sleep. But, you know, if you've watched your pet dog on the ground, when their thoughts start falling asleep,
但是的，我认为它们拥有我们做梦时的大脑状态。我认为它们可能在某种程度上做梦。唯一，唯一关于动物做梦的轻微证据报告来自佩妮·帕特森，她拥有大猩猩可可和迈克尔。可可去世了，我相信。但可可曾经在醒来时签署某种奇妙的场景，而不是其他时间。她会签署关于汽车在天空中飞行的内容，或者她会签署关于看到一个她实际上已经六个月没见的人的内容。而那些非真实的奇妙事情似乎只发生在醒来时。
my dog barks and she, you know, twitches or likes, that sort of thing. So it looks like they're dreaming, you know, as far as we can tell. But so do animals dream and how do we know if they do or don't? Well, that's a very, that's a very good question. I tend to assume that they do. We know that all mammals except cetaceans. Whales and dolphins do not have REM sleep. They have this strange sleep where they sleep with one hand.
我的狗会叫，你知道，会抽搐或者类似的事情。所以看起来它们在做梦，据我们所知。但是动物真的会做梦吗？我们怎么知道它们是否会做梦呢？嗯，这是一个非常好的问题。我倾向于认为它们会。我们知道除了鲸目动物以外的所有哺乳动物。鲸鱼和海豚没有快速眼动睡眠。它们有一种奇怪的睡眠方式，就是用半个大脑睡觉。
half of their brain at a talk. But all other mammals have alternate between non-rimmed sleep and rapid eye movement sleep and their brain has activity that looks very similar to hours when we are dreaming. So I am willing to make the leap and say that I think that mammals are dreaming in whatever they're elephant or mousy or doggy or catty version of that. is some of my colleagues would not, would not say that. I mean, that some of my colleagues would not assume any consciousness to other mammalian species or only passed a certain level in the evolutionary hierarchy.
但所有其他哺乳动物都在非快速眼动睡眠和快速眼动睡眠之间交替，它们的大脑活动看起来与我们做梦时非常相似。所以我愿意大胆推测，我认为哺乳动物确实在做梦，无论是大象、老鼠、狗还是猫的版本。我的一些同事可能不会这么说。我的意思是，我的一些同事不会认为其他哺乳动物物种具有任何意识，或者认为只有进化等级达到一定水平的物种才具备。
But yeah, I think they have the same brain state that we dream in. I think they're probably dreaming in some way. The only, the only slight evidence for dreamer, reports from animals are Penny Patterson who had the guerrillas Coco and Michael. Coco died, I believe. But Coco used to sign kind of fantastic scenarios right upon awakening and no other time. She'd sign about cars flying through the sky, or she'd sign something about seeing a person who she actually hadn't seen in six months. And those sort of signing not real fantastic things only seemed to happen upon awakening.
但是的，我认为它们拥有与我们做梦时相同的大脑状态。我认为它们可能在某种程度上做梦。关于动物做梦的唯一一点证据来自佩妮·帕特森，她曾照顾过大猩猩可可和迈克尔。我相信可可已经去世了。但可可过去常在醒来时用手语描述一些奇幻的场景，其他时间则不会。她会用手语描述汽车在天空中飞翔，或者描述看到一个她实际上已经六个月没见的人。而这些关于非现实奇幻事物的描述似乎只发生在醒来时。
So Penny assumed that those were dream reports. And, you know, you could argue about that. But I think that sounds quite likely. And the gorilla Michael, who didn't have quite as big assigned vocabulary, but I guess he's still learning. He's certainly still alive and well. He was known to have had his entire extended family group killed by poachers. And then he was picked up as an infant and sold through several iterations. And eventually went to Penny's Reserve.
所以佩妮认为那些是梦境报告。当然，你可以对此有不同看法。但我认为这听起来很有可能。大猩猩迈克尔虽然没有被分配到那么大的词汇量，但我猜他仍在学习。他肯定还活得好好的。众所周知，他的整个大家族都被偷猎者杀害了。后来他还是个婴儿时就被带走，经过多次转手。最终去了佩妮的保护区。
He had a very traumatic killing of all of his family in front of him. And she said that he used to wake up signing bad people kill gorillas, bad people kill gorillas. And again, only in the morning. So she interpreted that not just as a memory, but as seeming like he was probably having a post-traumatic dream about the event. And again, that's very soft evidence. It's an end of two. It's very subjective. It's fun to think about.
他亲眼目睹了全家被杀的惨剧，这对他造成了极大的创伤。她说他过去常在醒来时用手语比划“坏人杀大猩猩，坏人杀大猩猩”。而且同样，只在早上。所以她不仅将其解读为一种记忆，还认为这看起来很像他可能正在做关于那件事的创伤后梦境。再说一次，这只是非常软性的证据。样本量只有两个。这非常主观。但思考这些很有趣。
But possibly we have dream accounts from two gorillas. But just in general, they are having the same brain state as REM sleep. So I think it's likely that they're dreaming. Now, they're not necessarily dreaming when they're twitching and moving, though, because in humans, although there's something called REM behavior disorder where you act out your dreams, We are, we and other mammals are supposed to be paralyzed during REM sleep and normal, healthy people and animals. That is the case. Where sleepwalking in non-REM sleep is much more common for people.
但我们可能确实有来自两只大猩猩的梦境记录。但总的来说，它们处于与快速眼动睡眠（REM）相同的脑状态。所以我认为它们很可能在做梦。不过，它们在抽搐和移动时并不一定是在做梦，因为在人类中，虽然有一种叫做快速眼动睡眠行为障碍的疾病，你会把梦境演出来，但我们和其他哺乳动物在快速眼动睡眠期间应该是瘫痪的，对于正常、健康的人和动物来说，情况确实如此。而非快速眼动睡眠期间的梦游对人类来说要常见得多。
And so I think that most times that you see much activity during sleep, you know, when dogs are are woofing or moving their legs a lot as they, that's, probably out of non-rim sleep, which just seems to be mild slight activity in motor areas that's not associated with a big dream scenario in humans. Human sleepwalkers usually don't recall anything or it's a very simple I was trying to get from place A to place B rather than a dream account. So I think when you see your dog making the most noise and moving the most, it's not necessarily dreaming. If when you see its eyelids moving rapidly under its eyes, even if it's completely still, that's when it's likely to be dreaming. Okay, interesting. I'll pay more attention there, my dog's eyes.
所以我认为，大多数时候你看到睡眠中有大量活动，比如狗在呜呜叫或腿部大幅度移动时，那可能是在非快速眼动睡眠期间，这似乎只是运动区域轻微的活动，在人类中并不与大型梦境场景相关。人类梦游者通常不记得任何事情，或者只是非常简单的“我试图从A地走到B地”，而不是梦境描述。所以我认为当你看到你的狗发出最大的声音和移动最多时，它不一定是在做梦。如果当你看到它的眼睑在眼下快速移动时，即使它完全静止，那才是它可能在做梦的时候。好的，很有趣。我会多注意我狗的眼睛。
And when you and I spoke before, we talked about lucid dreaming, which I know that the journal dreaming has touched on in various ways. And you've said it's also become a topic in popular culture since the movie Inception came out a number of years ago. So can you explain more about what lucid dreaming is? Well, the definition is simply that it's a dream in which you know it's a dream. At some point, you're going, this isn't real. I'm dreaming. Many people, once they're lucid, they then have a lot of control over the dream. If they're being chased down a hall by which they can choose, no, I don't want to have a witch dream anymore and, you know, dissolve the door.
在你我上次交谈时，我们谈到了清醒梦，我知道《梦境》杂志以各种方式触及过这个话题。你说自从几年前电影《盗梦空间》上映以来，它也成为了流行文化中的一个话题。那么你能多解释一下什么是清醒梦吗？嗯，定义很简单，就是你知道自己在做梦的梦。在某个时刻，你会想，这不是真的。我在做梦。许多人在清醒后，会对梦境有很大的控制权。如果他们被一个女巫追赶，他们可以选择，不，我不想再做女巫的梦了，然后，你知道，让门消失。
dark building into a beautiful palace or being outdoors and some and some of their friends instead of the witch. So some people can switch a dream all around once they know they're lucid, but not everyone. So the definition is simply knowing your dreaming, even if the dream keeps unfolding in a very dreamlike way. And most people really enjoy lucid dreams. There's occasionally people stay distressed by by scary content but usually even if you let the witch stay there and you turn around and ask her why she's chasing you and what she represents once you know she's a dream witch you're not scared anymore so most lucid dreams are are very positive and people enjoy having them so what does that mean exactly does that mean part of
黑暗的建筑变成了一座美丽的宫殿，或者是在户外，和一些朋友在一起，而不是女巫。所以有些人一旦知道自己清醒，就可以完全改变梦境，但并非所有人都能做到。所以定义仅仅是知道你在做梦，即使梦境继续以非常梦幻的方式展开。大多数人真的很享受清醒梦。偶尔有人会对可怕的内容感到困扰，但通常即使你让女巫留在那里，你转过身问她为什么要追你，她代表什么，一旦你知道她是一个梦中的女巫，你就不再害怕了。所以大多数清醒梦是非常积极的，人们喜欢做这些梦。那么这到底意味着什么？这是否意味着在那一刻你的部分意识被开启了？
is part of your consciousness turned on at that moment Yes, the EEGs of people having lucid dreams, I mean, back in the 80s it was established that they really did seem to be in rapid eye movement sleep. And that was big news because it had been sort of questioned maybe they're waking up into some sort of fantasy waking state. But Steve LaBerge proved that people having lucid dreams are really in rapid eye movement sleep. and that's about all that sleep labs could tell at that time. But more recently, now that there are much, you can put on many more tiny EEG leads and reconstruct a much better 3D image of what's going on in the brain, what that shows is that the person is basically in rapid eye movement sleep,
是的，做清醒梦的人的脑电图，我的意思是，早在80年代就已经确定他们确实似乎处于快速眼动睡眠中。这可是个大新闻，因为之前有人质疑他们是否醒来进入了某种幻想的清醒状态。但史蒂夫·拉伯格证明了做清醒梦的人确实处于快速眼动睡眠中。而这基本上就是当时睡眠实验室所能告诉我们的全部了。但最近，现在有了更多微小的脑电图导联，可以重建大脑中正在发生的事情的更好的3D图像，这表明该人基本上处于快速眼动睡眠中，
but it's not a completely typical episode of rapid eye movement sleep. the prefrontal cortex, the area right behind our forehead that has a lot to do with abstract thinking is very much damped down during REM sleep. It's often misstated that it's turned off or something in REM sleep. That's not true. There is activity there at a lower level, even in normal REM sleep. But in lucid dreams, there is usually a little more activity in the prefrontal cortex than there is during other rim periods. And that's exactly the area where noticing
但这并不是一个完全典型的快速眼动睡眠片段。前额叶皮层，即我们前额后面与抽象思维密切相关的区域，在快速眼动睡眠期间被大大抑制了。人们常误以为它在快速眼动睡眠中被关闭了，这不正确。即使在正常的快速眼动睡眠中，那里也有较低水平的活动。但在清醒梦中，前额叶皮层的活动通常比其他快速眼动睡眠期间要多一点。而这正是注意到
discrepancies, the fact that the prefrontal is damped down during most dreams is why we don't question, you know, bizarre. You know, most of the time if we're flying, we're just thrilled to be flying, not questioning how we can. You know, if somebody that you know is dead is showing up in your dream, you usually don't question how that can be. Sometimes you do. So that area that notices things are odd or just even reflects on what's the nature of this experience, that's just turned back up not as much as on average as when we're awake, but somewhat more than in typical dreams. So that seems to be necessary for lucid dreaming.
差异的区域，前额叶在大多数梦中被抑制，这就是为什么我们不质疑那些离奇的事情。你知道，大多数时候如果我们正在飞行，我们只是为能飞行而感到兴奋，而不是质疑我们怎么能飞行。你知道，如果一个你认识的死者出现在你的梦里，你通常不会质疑这是怎么回事。有时你会。所以那个注意到事情很奇怪，或者甚至反思这种体验本质的区域，只是被重新开启了，虽然平均来说没有我们清醒时那么强，但比在典型的梦中要多一些。所以这似乎是清醒梦所必需的。
That's interesting. And what are you currently doing with your dreaming, research? Well, the most recent research study that I finished was a comparison of the content of dream accounts to the content of sleep talking episodes, finding that they were similar in many ways compared to waking speech. They both express much more fear than we typically talk about awake. They're less set in the present than our waking topics. But then there's some differences like there's much, much more anger in sleep talking
这很有趣。你目前在梦境研究方面在做什么？嗯，我完成的最新研究是对梦境报告内容与梦话片段内容的比较，发现它们在许多方面与清醒时的言语相似。它们都表达了比我们清醒时通常谈论的更多的恐惧。它们不像我们清醒时的话题那样立足于当下。但也有一些差异，比如梦话中有更多更多的愤怒，
than in either dreams or awake, dreams in waking speech have much more in common in terms of pretty low levels of anger from most people. And sleep talking involves much more anger. So that was my most recent research study, and I'm not starting another one real soon because I'm trying to finish a book, which is kind of a sequel to my book, The Committee of Sleep, which is all about dreams and creative problem solving. I both have more theoretical things that I want to say about it. But also, once that book came out, while I was writing it, I had to chase down people who'd have amazing problems. solving dreams. But once it came out, I was getting letters from, including some famous, you know, ones with major accomplishments that had come from a dream that I didn't know about. So,
比在梦中或清醒时都要多，梦境和清醒时的言语在大多数人的愤怒水平较低方面有更多共同点。而梦话涉及更多的愤怒。所以这是我最近的研究，我不会很快开始另一项研究，因为我正在努力完成一本书，这算是我的书《睡眠委员会》的续集，那本书是关于梦境和创造性问题解决的。我既有更多想说的理论性东西。而且，那本书出版后，在我写它的时候，我不得不去追寻那些有惊人问题解决梦境的人。但一旦它出版了，我就收到了信件，包括一些名人，你知道，那些有重大成就的人，他们的成就来自一个我不知道的梦。所以，
great. More content for you. Yeah. Great. When is that coming out? It's not even in press yet. It's probably coming out in a year and a half, I would guess. But it's, it's more of a focus than research right now. So Dr. Barr, can you talk about what you dream about? Well, my dreams are, they're probably more similar to other dream researchers than to the average person. Because with only one, I know one dream researcher who says that he would just at a grad school where the person doing the most interesting research who wanted the most research assistance and was the most charismatic figure was doing dream research and that he personally had never thought about much about dreams until getting to grad school. But most dream researchers are drawn to the field because we remember more dreams than average.
太棒了。你有更多内容了。是的。太棒了。那本书什么时候出版？还没付印呢。我猜大概一年半后会出版。但它现在比研究更受关注。那么巴雷特博士，你能谈谈你梦见什么吗？嗯，我的梦可能比普通人更像其他梦境研究者。因为我只认识一位梦境研究者，他说他刚从研究生院出来，当时做最有趣研究、想要最多研究助理且最有魅力的人正在做梦境研究，而他个人在进入研究生院之前从未想过太多关于梦的事情。但大多数梦境研究者被吸引到这个领域是因为我们比一般人记得更多的梦。
Our dreams are more vivid than average. We tend to have more lucid dreams and flying dreams and just almost any unusual category of dreams that you mention that will have a certain low base rate in the general population. I and other dream researchers have more of. So I was just always fascinated by all these nocturnal adventures, which I did remember more of in more detail than the average person. And I think a lot of psychologists go to grad school and then pick a specialty within psychology. But for me, it was much more the other way around. I was just focused on dreams as this fascinating thing as a kid.
我们的梦比一般人更生动。我们往往有更多的清醒梦和飞行梦，几乎你提到的任何不寻常的梦境类别，在普通人群中都有一定的低基准率。我和其他梦境研究者有更多。所以我一直对所有这些夜间冒险着迷，我确实记得比一般人更多、更详细的梦。我认为很多心理学家去读研究生，然后选择心理学内的一个专业。但对我来说，情况恰恰相反。我从小就专注于梦，认为它是一件迷人的事情。
And as I got to be a little older, I realized if someone was going to pay you to study dreams, you better go to graduate school in psychology. So I don't have any way of characterizing. You know, I have all the things we've talked about, recurring dreams, lucid dreams, problem-solving dreams, a few nightmares, not particularly. high rate of those. And I have dreams that have solved very practical problems. I have many more dreams that I think are more about my interpersonal, emotional issues where I dream about people who are important to me and in the dream I'm doing something different than the way I'd usually react to them. And I wake up and realize that that has some implications for things to do in real life.
随着我长大一点，我意识到如果有人要付钱让你研究梦，你最好去读心理学研究生。所以我没有任何表征方式。你知道，我有我们谈过的所有东西，重复的梦、清醒梦、解决问题的梦、一些噩梦，但频率不是特别高。我也有解决过非常实际问题的梦。我有更多我认为更多是关于我人际关系、情感问题的梦，我梦见对我重要的人，在梦中我做的事情与我通常对他们的反应不同。我醒来后意识到这对现实生活中要做的事情有一些启示。
I have some dreams that are just so gorgeous visually that I've started making art from my dreams. I've just been doing that for about three years, but I sold some art and have some art and art shows. And it's all dream art. I have no interest in making art other than to represent some of these images that I just want to drag back into the waking world for other people to see them. I did see that actually when I was just looking into researching this topic. I saw your artwork and it was striking, striking beautiful, very colorful. And can you describe what your favorite piece of art you created? Probably a pair.
我有一些梦在视觉上非常华丽，以至于我开始根据我的梦创作艺术。我做这件事大约三年了，但我卖掉了一些艺术品，也参加了一些艺术展。而且全是梦境艺术。除了想表现一些我只想带回清醒世界让别人看到的图像外，我对创作艺术没有兴趣。我在研究这个话题时确实看到了。我看到了你的艺术作品，非常引人注目，非常美丽，色彩非常丰富。你能描述一下你创作的最喜欢的艺术作品吗？可能是一对。
Most dreams I just make one piece of art from them. But I had a dream where I was walking through Harvard Square, which is the neighborhood where I live, late at night. And I was discovering these little animals up on the rooftops. and thinking they must have been living there all the years I did, and I just never looked up and seen them before. And then eventually they were down in the street, and I was thinking, oh, they only come down late at night.
大多数梦我只创作一件艺术品。但我做过一个梦，梦见我深夜走在哈佛广场，那是我住的社区。我发现屋顶上有这些小动物，心想它们一定在我住的所有年头里都住在那儿，只是我从来没抬头看过它们。然后最终它们到了街上，我想，哦，它们只在深夜才下来。
And in the dream I thought, and I've never been in the middle of Harvard Square in the middle of the night. That's extremely not true. But in the dream it was. So I was discovering these wonderful animals that live on the roof and come down into the streets. And so I actually went down and photographed several different buildings that were on this route through the square.
在梦里我想，而且我从来没有在深夜去过哈佛广场的中心。那完全不是真的。但在梦里确实是。所以我发现了这些住在屋顶上并下到街上的奇妙动物。所以我实际上去拍了几座在这个广场路线上不同的建筑。
But it was one of the Harvard Lampoon building and another of a spot called Charlie's Kitchen that are just interesting buildings that are kind of lit up interestingly at night anyway. And they had the most captured the feel of the dream before I started adding all the little magical creatures up on the roof and spilling down into the street. So I guess it was the happiest.
但其中一个是哈佛讽刺剧社大楼，另一个是一个叫查理厨房的地方，它们本身就是有趣的建筑，晚上灯光也很有趣。在我开始在屋顶上添加所有小魔法生物并溢出到街道上之前，它们最能捕捉到梦的感觉。所以我猜我是最开心的。
with the two I made out of that dream came out, really just as I'd seen them in the dream. And what do you use for materials? Is it a painting? Is it a sculpture? No, it's digitally manipulated photography. So for a few of them, like one, I dreamed about a mask changing all these ways. I found that I really love masks. So I take pictures when I go to mask exhibits. So I already had enough pictures of masks to start morphing into that dream. But for the one I just mentioned, I went down, took pictures of the building, and so a real photograph of the building was the basic backdrop. And I left the sky and the brick in certain areas unchanged so that it kind of looks photographically real. But then I played somewhat with the surface of the building, but mainly I put in.
用那个梦做的两件作品出来时，真的就像我在梦中看到的那样。你用什么材料？是绘画吗？是雕塑吗？不，是数字处理过的摄影。所以对于其中一些，比如一个，我梦见一个面具以各种方式变化。我发现我真的很喜欢面具。所以我去参观面具展时会拍照。所以我已经有足够的面具照片开始变形到那个梦里了。但对于我刚才提到的那个，我下去拍了建筑的照片，所以建筑的真实照片是基本背景。我保留了天空和砖块在某些区域不变，这样它看起来在摄影上是真实的。但我稍微处理了建筑的表面，但主要是放入了。
little creatures, some of which I created from scratch in digital programs and others. I actually took photographs not of real animals, but of like little carvings of already not quite realistic animals and manipulated them a little bit more digitally. So it's always collaged photography within lots and lots of digital manipulation to give it the surreal look that the dream had. So dreams are also inspiration for you as well. Yes, definitely. I mean, they've been inspiration for, you know, things in my research life and work as a clinician
小生物，其中一些是我在数字程序中从零开始创作的，另一些。我实际上拍的不是真实动物的照片，而是像一些本来就不太写实的小动物雕刻，并稍微在数字上处理了一下它们。所以它总是拼贴摄影，加上大量的数字处理，以赋予它梦境所具有的超现实外观。所以梦也是你的灵感来源。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，它们长期以来一直是我的研究生活、临床工作和人际关系的灵感来源。
and interpersonal relationships for a long time. And I'd only been writing about art from dreams. But lately, it's, yeah, all of my art is completely inspired by dreams. Well, that's wonderful. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Barrett. Nice, nice to talk to you. If you've been a long time listener or are new to our show, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes or if you have time, write a review. We'd really appreciate it. Also, we'd like to hear from you directly. So if you have any comments about the show or ideas for us, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue about new psychological research and progress. notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever
我以前只写过关于梦境艺术的文章。但最近，是的，我所有的艺术作品完全受到梦境的启发。嗯，那太棒了。非常感谢你加入我们，巴雷特博士。很高兴和你交谈。如果你是我们的老听众或者是新听众，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分，或者如果你有时间，写一篇评论。我们将不胜感激。此外，我们想直接听听你的意见。所以如果你对节目有任何评论或想法，请发邮件给我，地址是K-Luna@APA.org。那是K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他播客，如《APA期刊对话》，关于新的心理学研究和进展，以及关于心理学实践的笔记。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何地方找到我们所有的播客，
you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org, and listen to more episodes and to see more resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你获取播客的地方。你也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集并查看我们讨论主题的更多资源。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。